Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is a quick update on our plans with Two
Minute Papers.
The more I look at our incredibly high quality
comments sections on YouTube or the community
efforts that started out on our subreddit,
the more I get the feeling that we should
strive to create a community platform around
the series.
A platform for people who wish to learn, exchange
ideas, collaborate, and help each other.
For instance, the Two Minute Papers Data project
has recently started.
The initial idea is that there would be a
public crowdsourced database with episode-related
metadata that anyone can add information to.
This would be useful for several different
reasons.
We can, for instance, include implementation
links for each of the papers, for the ones
that have source code either from the authors
or some independent implementations from the
community.
We can also include keywords on the topic
of the episode, such as machine learning,
recurrent neural networks, cloth simulations
for an easy way to search for a topic of interest.
If we are interested in any of these, we can
just easily search for a keyword and immediately
know what episode it was referenced in.
The very same could be done with some of the
technical words used in the series, such as
Metropolis sampling, backpropagation and overfitting.
This way, we could maybe build an intuitive
technical dictionary with definitions and
links pointing to the appropriate episodes
where they were explained.
I think that would be the ultimate learning
resource and having such a dictionary would
be super useful - I was playing with the thought
of having this for quite a while now.
So this data project has just started out
on the Two Minute Papers subreddit, but it
can only happen with the help of the community
- and this means you.
If you're interested in helping, please drop
by and leave us a note, I've put a link in
the description box.
Looking forward to seeing you there!
It seems that there is interest in doing such
collaborations and experiments together between
you Fellow Scholars.
Imagine how cool it would be to see students
and researchers forming an open and helpful
community, brainstorming, running the implementations,
and sharing their ideas and findings with
each other.
Who knows, maybe one day, a science paper
will be written as a result of such endeavors.
Please let us know in the comments section
what you think about these things.
Would you participate in such an endeavor?
As always, we love reading your awesome feedback!
Also, in the meantime, a huge thank you for
the following Fellow Scholars who translated
our episodes to several languages!
If you wish to contribute too, click the cogwheel
button in any video on the lower right, click
subtitles/CC, then add subtitles/CC.
I am trying my very best to credit every contributor,
if I have forgotten anyone, that's not intended,
please let me know and I'll fix it.
Meanwhile, on Patreon, we are currently oscillating
around our current milestone.
Reaching this one means that all of our software
and hardware costs are covered, which is quite
amazing.
Because creating YouTube videos with high
information density and short duration is
the very definition of financial suicide,
it's very helpful for us to have such a safety
net with Patreon.
Also, there was an episode not so long ago
about the new Two Minute Papers machine which
was bought solely from your support, and I
am still stunned by this.
I tried to explain this to close members of
the family that we were able to buy this new
machine with the support of complete strangers
from the internet whom I've never met.
They said that this is clearly impossible.
Apparently, it's not impossible - and so many
kind people are watching the series, really,
thank you so much!
When we reach our milestone after that, we
will be able to spend 1% of these funds to
directly help other research projects and
conferences.
Please remember that your support makes Two
Minute Papers possible, and you can cancel
these pledges at any time.
Also, if you don't feel like using Patreon
or don't have any disposable income, that
is completely fine.
I'd like to emphasize that none of this is
required, it's just an option to help, and
we completely understand that it's not easy
to make ends meet for many many of you, even
with lots of overtime at a tiring and difficult
job.
Two Minute Papers is always going to be here
and will always be free for everyone.
We would like to spread the word so even more
of us can marvel at the wonders of research.
Just watching the series and sharing these
episodes is also a great deal of help and
we are super grateful for it!
It is really incredible to see how the series
has grown and how many of you Fellow Scholars
are interested in research, and the inventions
of the future.
Let's continue our journey of science together!
In the meantime, Google DeepMind and Blizzard
has announced a joint effort to make it possible
for computer programs to play Starcraft 2,
a famous real-time strategy game from the
start of 2017.
Whoa!
There was a question about the first thing
I will do when this project takes off.
Well, of course, I'll take one week of vacation
and write an AI that can play against itself
and watch with tremendous enjoyment as they
beat the living hell out of each other and
other real players.
If I heard it correctly, in one of the upcoming
championships, computer algorithms will also
be allowed to play.
And who knows, maybe defeat the reigning player
champions, you know, like in Chess and Go.
We're living amazing times indeed.
I am counting the days.
Super excited.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!